a very good morning to you sir
Christopher thanks very much indeed for
talking to us first of all your reaction
to the last 24 hours and the resignation
of Liz truss
well I think it's appalling actually and
I I apologize I feel ashamed of my
revolting colleagues actually they
brought down another prime minister and
that's the same people who are largely
responsible who brought down Boris
Johnson and we're now in a dire State
because basically the conservative
parliamentary party has proved itself to
be ungovernable and that's going to be a
problem that will beset any successor
unless that successor gets a mandate
from the British people a fresh mandate
for the British people and I think that
will calm the Parliamentary party and
hopefully they will then have some
respect for the new leader
so you blame your fellow Tory MPS you
call them revolting but some would say
that Liz truss has brought this on
herself it was her mini budget that
caused such upset in the markets or the
cost of borrowing rise and people's
mortgage costs go up no no no that's not
correct she was being undermined from
the moment that she had been chosen by
58 of the the people in the in the
country and the conservative members as
our our leader when she went to the
Party Conference she was being
undermined by Michael Gove and others
and then when she came forward with I
thought it was an excellent proposal to
put a cap on Energy prices as that
caused a an issue in the in the markets
and instead of trying to calm things
down her detractors tried to make it
even more difficult for her and the
consequence and says we've now lost a
prime minister who had some really good
ideas on on growth and low taxes and we
are now in a milestone
and in a Maelstrom now so who do you
want to see take over then
well I I don't see that there's really
um any of the candidates are coming
forward are
going to command my support and I think
that the news that Boris Johnson might
be riding to the rescue of the country
and the conservative party is really a
great tonic and I'm really excited about
that Prospect because I didn't want him
to be deposed in the first place I said
we'd Rue the day that he was deposed
sadly I've been proved right on that but
I think that if we had Boris back then
he's already got a mandate from the
British people and my email box is full
up with people saying they want to have
Boris back so I see him as the uh the
great hope
and yet that's interesting he did of
course uh you know win a majority in
2019 but just before he resigned 69 of
the public according to the polls wanted
him to go he also lost the confidence of
the party as well didn't he modern 60
MPS resigned in protest at him being
prime minister
well that was 60. um but of course he
tried to have a a government from all
parts of the the party and what happened
in the end was that he was undermined by
those people who are not real
conservatives and I'm afraid there are
too many people in the Parliamentary
party who are not real conservatives
he's still under investigation for the
the Privileges committee there's an
investigation still going on over
whether he misled Parliament that could
be problematic couldn't it
well I I just I discount that I think
that if we elect him as our new uh prime
minister then um he will command the
authority of a majority of my
parliamentary colleagues and if people
want to have noises off then they can
continue to to do that but I can't
comment on on the the work of the of the
Privileges committee except to say that
they seem to have set themselves a very
low bar for finding him guilty by uh not
uh requiring that it should have been a
deliberate misleading he never he never
deliberately misled the House of Commons
Richie sunac hasn't formally declared
yet but it's widely thought that he will
step forward some people will say he's
the Natural Choice given that he came
second he was runner-up to Liz truss and
went through that whole leadership
campaign that lasted so many weeks over
the summer
well he's certainly not mine uh Natural
Choice nor that of my constituents
because he was involved in undermining
Boris Johnson and showed his disloyalty
and I don't think did you ever hear him
come to speak out in support of Liz
trust and say we should give her a bit
of time and be allow her a bit of room
in order to develop her policies no he
didn't he he and his acolytes were
continually undermining her so I think
if you want to have a further divided
conservative party
um choose Rishi sunak but if you want a
United party he's not the answer
so do you think this trust did nothing
wrong
well I'm not saying that she she did
nothing wrong she admits herself that
she she may made mistakes uh and
um that's uh fair enough but uh are we
that unforgiving as a as a party we call
ourselves compassionate conservatives
but I haven't seen from a lot of my
colleagues any compassion whatsoever for
for his trust and her family and I think
that's unacceptable
if Boris Johnson doesn't run do you want
a general election
I think there should be a general
election because we need
um whoever becomes the leader if it's
not Boris Johnson we need to have the uh
a proper mandate and the only way to get
a proper mandate is to go to the people
and I'm not pessimistic about the
outcome of a general election now on the
issue of putting our economy oh right do
we want to have Rachel Reeves and chaos
starmer and all the left in the labor
party are campaigning for higher taxes
and more uh Trade Union uh disruption or
do we want to have a conservative
government with a taking a fresh line on
the economy if some of my friends and in
the party had more confidence in our
policies as then they wouldn't be so
pessimistic about the prospects of an
early general election
okay so Christopher thanks very much
indeed for your time this morning we
appreciate it